there's a company whose CEO is an icon
that has product events that are
attended by thousands of fans whose
smartphones and tablets are owned by
millions of people it might sound like
I'm talking about Apple it's actually a
Chinese company that you may not have
heard of called Xiaomi Xiaomi is a four
year old company
it's basically rethought the way
smartphones are made advertised and sold
you can't buy the company's phones and
stores they sell them only online they
don't advertise on television but
they've got a lot of buzz on social
media Xiaomi takes the money that it
saves on advertising on the retail
margin and then votes it to driving the
cost of its gadgets down a meat bone and
China might cost us a few hundred
dollars an iPhone and China good for
seven or eight hundred dollars that's
why cost-conscious Chinese consumers
love them Xiaomi is on fire right now
investors love them the company's been
valued at ten billion dollars lychee was
already very successful before starting
Xiaomi he was the longtime CEO of a
software maker called King sock he was a
famous angel investor he still felt like
he had something to prove
he actually put together an extremely
strong founding team of Chinese
executives from Google and Microsoft
they drew lessons from companies like
Apple and Amazon in just four years they
built the six largest smartphone maker
in the world and the third largest in
China
Xiaomi truly has global ambitions and
recent must have gone into Taiwan
Singapore and Malaysia
they've also identified markets like
Mexico and Brazil they think they can
target this year the big question is
whether a Chinese smartphone brand can
truly go global Xiaomi has a lot of
advantages
home-country inspires patriotism and its
customers and they're accustomed to
buying phones online and not in stores
in other countries it loses home-field
advantage that it's going head to head
with some truly global Giants like
Samsung and Apple